like you asked that how many genders
there are we don't need to define that
there can be an infinite number of
genders is all about what you define I
could go around wearing a dress if
that's what I particularly wanted but
are you still a boy then because you
have a penis
I don't assume time for the latest
installment of changed my mind where we
rationalize our positions on
controversial topics this week is our
second installment of the student
edition series revisiting the topic of
they're only being too generous now of
course the idea that there are more than
two genders seems to be a hot topic
these days I think it's disrespectful to
force somebody to use pronouns they're
being invented by the day
they're know I'm being bunted by the day
I don't know where you're getting that
information how many genders are there
how many things are there there I can't
define the number of genders or the
number of pronouns because anyone can
determine them they are being invented
by the day people we have to listen to
the science and the science says we're
all on a spectrum excuse me it's ma'am
it is ma'am as always sound off below
your thoughts on the topic what topics
you'd like to see most in the future and
in this case how you think the students
presented their arguments now it should
be noted that as in the last episode of
the UT Dean of Student Activities forbid
us from having two students behind the
desk at one time hence the awkward
workaround
time to meet the first two students Sam
and Parker so I want to make sure that
we understand kind of the general Khan
and I know sorry
there's a lot of people so you might not
all be able to hear right now Sam is on
the change by my side of a fence here so
you know it's your position your job to
state your position in the affirmative
and allow someone else to try and
convince you otherwise so it's kind of a
little bit of an attack and defend ideas
right yes Sam believes there are two
genders and sorry but we can Harker
Parker believes that there are more than
two genders so Sam you know how to set
this up yep invite him - hi Parker hey
so I believe that there are only two
genders and I'd be willing to have you
try to change my mind okay Parker I
believe that there are more than two and
I'd be willing to change his mind I
think I can I believe in myself yeah
okay are we are we supposed to start
yeah
okay I'm already behind a rope I feel
like I've lost but I'm gonna say the are
are not it's like arguing something's
existence it's like arguing the
existence of God so I feel like gender
expression is kind of a different thing
where people can find their own
communities of people who feel feel
similarly who feel uncomfortable in
their own skin and it provides them an
opportunity to to blossom socially that
otherwise they might not have if they
were lying about their identity or if it
continued to be uncomfortable in their
own skin sure okay so I'm a believer
that there's a difference between how
you like how you feel and what you
actually are made up of right so I could
I could pretend I'm a unicorn and go to
a unicorns meeting you know and and feel
like that's including me in a society
but that doesn't mean I'm a unicorn
right obviously those people are called
furries they exist and they're very
happy with their communities so based
based on science and by all the saints
on biology and science from par those
people unicorns though no they're not
but I mean you can't that's something
that can never change you know it's
about your brain chemistry and about the
way that you're made up the the identity
is a way of circumventing that like if
you if you feel like you were born wrong
the the opposing view would be that's
just how it is and you're kind of stuck
but this new school of thought allows
people to be much more comfortable with
who they are and not have it be tethered
to something that they can't change so I
guess I guess what I'd say to that is I
think there's a so can you give me the
difference between just feeling like
you're something versus actually being
it what makes me if I feel like I'm a
woman what makes me actually be a woman
versus just saying hey I'm a woman well
that's the debate and I don't think I
don't think conflating biology with that
there's a difference between brain
chemistry and biology like if you're a
born biologically male your brain
chemistry might you might have more
estrogen than the average male maybe and
you might lean towards one side a little
bit more and that can regenerate but
genetically are you still a man well I
mean genetically everyone is we
genetically we only exist in two forms
but I feel like ostracizing the argument
too you know of course of course there
are men and women but we've created more
schools of thought more ways for people
to express themselves physically okay so
if we're creating them that means that
they're not natural correct not natural
if they're man-made that means they're
not natural right that whole non natural
thing brings up to don't look to me this
is between you two right no but it's
it's it's usually you I don't like this
gimmick and I will not be watching this
video I'm sorry look I don't mean to be
crass I don't mean to be rude the bottom
line is of course biologically the human
animal has do all other animals they
only exist in two binary forms yes okay
so there are two genders then that's
what that's what my stance is you really
backed me into a corner my friend this
is uh this is more arguing that we've
reached a place mentally where we're
expanding ourselves to more schools of
thought that might result in interesting
and new philosophies to move us forward
and maybe have us be more harmonious
with one another and that's fair like
that's something where I I will say
those are thoughts right you say those
are thoughts and ever anyone can have
thoughts and I feel like how they ever
want right but that's what they are they
remain to be thoughts yeah there's a
difference between having a thought
about something and feeling a certain
way and actually biologically physically
being that thing yeah and so so that's
where you get into a kind of a gray area
right it's like what actually is
something that I physically can be what
versus what can I feel like I am well
and what we're trying to say here is
that there are two physical genders
there are two things that you can be
when you're born you're either XX or XY
chromosome right you're not gonna be X Y
and then Z za zing or whatever you can
be so you know the chromosomes those are
the two things that you are and that is
fact I feel like no one's saying that
you can't feel like whatever you want to
be right like I I'm not 21 years old and
you know I might want to grab a beer
every now and then I can't identifies 21
can I well even though that's what I
feel like I feel like I feel like the
part of the human experience is having
things in your head that you create and
manifest into real life so if you want
to manifest your own identity or your
own way of being perceived or perceiving
yourself I think you should be able to
do that without people saying that it's
not natural so biologically again I have
a question for so do you believe like
since I'm not 21 if I want to go grab a
beer down at the bar can I say I feel
like I'm 21
I can go down to the bar no but you can
buy a fake ID and for all intents and
purposes you are 21 but that's not true
first of all that's a crime second is it
is a crime second of all that's that
doesn't change the fact that my cells
aren't 21 years old right that my psyche
isn't 21 years old it's still not real
is my point so I can I can do all these
things to make myself feel like I'm
something that I'm not and sure maybe I
can feel that way right but at the scene
you see what I mean about the argument
that we're having is real versus not
real versus doesn't exist
yes but the argument of it's not real
might stunt people's ability or or
openness to try and socialize with these
groups or try to maybe explore their
identity Lord can I pause this here for
a second is that okay just because I
know you have a time limit so this is
kind of some that we run into a lot I
don't know who's watching who feels like
this has sort of gotten off into the
weeds a little bit I think that you're
both agreeing on a lot more than you
realize it seems to me but now you've
agreed from the beginning well it seems
to me that if I'm not mistaken you agree
you're saying that biological sex and
gender are different from each other
correct I don't think you can yeah yeah
they're different like you're saying
that it sounds to me like you're saying
prove it well I'm saying proven and I
yeah you can't
biologically change your gender and that
is why it's very hard for us to get
permits
so I think this is what's really
important this is one thing to your very
very logical I appreciate how articulate
you are but I think there can be a
faster path to kind of get into the
point here okay so yeah why do you
believe because you were talking about
not wanting to marginalize people and
how productive it can be for these
people to engage with their communities
I think I think you would agree with
that that people should have community
we had all three communities a good
thing we care about people but since you
you stated the affirmative that
biological sex and gender are different
what is that based on and I think that's
where you guys are missing each other a
little bit what is that based on it's
based on science and I'm more arguing
for sociology that I would guess okay so
biological sex and gender is based on
science now I can would you like to
follow up with this sure so if we're
talking about gender being based on
science when you are born there are two
chromosomes that define what gender you
are X X versus X Y that has nothing to
do with the psychological how I feel in
my brain you cannot magically change
your gender or your sex just based on
the inherent cells and DNA that makes up
your body that assigns and the the
common argument and the one that I was
kind of flipping around is that gender
and sex have kind of become separate in
terms of their meaning as people have
gone on what
for this installment we'll ignore that
guy because you can see the entire
extended altercation with Sedna by
joining mud club at lateral credit calm
slash mud Club not only do you get
exclusive daily and extended content but
due to the demonization of videos like
these it's the only way to ensure that
this content continues lot of credit
calm slash mud Club get yourself a
student discount while you're there this
is the problem is this is the kind of
thing that often this is what people
want in traditional media is someone
yelling out an insult and people
reacting we just had fifty I don't know
15 to 20 minutes of two people having a
conversation
you're the outlier you're the jerk okay
yeah all right we have to wrap this up
and then I'd like to sit down with Sam
so in conclusion I believe that we
should separate the word gender from the
term biological sex because it's been
claimed by people who want to use it in
a different way a more social way in
order to feel more comfortable with
themselves okay
all right thank you Parker I like to sit
with you Sam - terrific Thank You Parker
very appreciated I thought these
students did pretty well and I'd wanted
to see exactly what Sam thought along
with offering some pointers of my own
keep in mind the whole purpose behind
change my mind and these student
additions in particular is to help the
students and you watching learn how to
rationalize your own positions and
engage in productive conversations you
know things your professors are supposed
to do and one thing I'd like to kind of
clarify your - something that we've
discussed quite a bit you know this
isn't a debate and what I want to
encourage people here have really
learned the Socratic method in college
in high school show of hands who here
has actually been taught the Socratic
method in college how many people here
have been taught the Socratic method in
college or university okay
seems like few people the point - the
Socratic method is not to debate not to
score points but to actually examine
your own argument and see if it comes to
a logical conclusion quick question how
many people here can tell me what would
constitute a bad argument
ad hominem you know there's a couple
rules that shortly on well what you're
presenting so I I heard ad hominem
appeal to Authority these are things we
call logical fallacies but before we get
to that and I do want to get to that in
a second a bad argument is an argument
with a false premise or a conclusion
that doesn't necessarily correlate to
its premise a conclusion that does not
prove its premise that's what
constitutes a bad argument and so I
think it's important to keep that in
mind anytime you talk with professors
anytime you talk with other students
because as long as you keep that in mind
examining okay is what they're
presenting a good argument or a bad
argument is the premise true do we agree
on terminology do we agree in the data
presented does the conclusion directly
correlate and is it caused by what's
been presented in this premise and
examine your own arguments that same way
it necessitates a more productive
dialogue now I'd like to kind of go back
through this here with with Parker yeah
so one point he said no I don't believe
you said there are two genders and he
disagreed with you yeah right and you
went down kind of asking them some
questions here's I think something
that's pretty effective when you're
asked just asking a basic question the
outset so you can play Parker for a
second I believe there are only two
genders I believe there are only I'm
Parker Isis
I do not believe there are only two
genders change my mind okay it's not
true but so I think this is important
right here before you go on you kind of
guys missed each other what might be
more productive when you start that
conversation as he says well I don't
believe you've stayed in the affirmative
you believe there are two genders right
yeah he said I believe there are more
but you let him go on you got to let him
go down a rabbit trail without defining
it so I would just say okay how many are
there and no one ever answers that
question so if someone is going to stick
make a statement again we go back to
sort of the idea of logical fallacies
burden of proof someone can't place the
burden of proof back on you if you say I
believe there are two genders and this
is backed by centuries of biological
medicine science and they say well I
believe there are more without stating
in the affirmative with the same
certainty how many there are
that's what he that's it moves on to
shore but it doesn't change the fact
that one would need to answer how many
genders are there so if you it's not
really fair if you say there are two and
you're arguing with someone who says
well there are more you put a number on
it right yeah he hasn't and looking back
you think maybe that would have helped
you guys kind of see where you you agree
or disagree yeah I think I think it
would have gotten to the point a lot
faster I think that at least in this
particular issue it's very easy to yet
yeah I mean you have the burden of proof
they have the burden proof you're you're
the one with the solidified fact and I
think so I think that if you a lot of
these people if you can just there they
have the burden of proof because they're
the ones making these grand assertions
and so the minute that you ask them to
prove it either the Canada cannot and
that's how so how would you say this was
you see this exercise benefited you
absolutely yeah
I think I think it's good and I think
for especially out of campus like UT
which is so politically divisive and
very violent especially against the
conservative population I think it's
good to at the very least show some
exposure for our arguments and the logic
behind them I appreciate that you did it
so civilly and productively I know you
got a time with me I appreciate it and
everybody
thanks for the time Sam now it's time
for two other games students Colton and
Gilbert step right up
so you are obviously stating your
position in the affirmative yes and it's
your goal to change his mind all right
understand
okay so Colton go ahead state your
position in the affirmative I would say
that there are only two genders in the
world based on scientific reasoning
genetics in particular I believe that
gender being not connected to biological
reasoning would have to do with
psychological differences okay can you
speak a little louder just go in for
talk okay
and you're welcome to welcoming someone
to change your mind yes all right
Gilbert your floor sir all right once
again my name is Gilbert I believe that
there are more than two genders and
first of all I'd like to agree with you
i'ma start with an agreement that
psychologically there is a difference
between gender and sex just I believe we
can agree that you're either born with a
penis or you're born with a vagina right
I've called that is your sex now it's to
me and to a lot of people I believe
gender is what you what it what you want
you to find yourself in society like is
not connected to whether to what you
have in your pants it's connected to how
you present yourself to the world
see I that's where I think the argument
first started like 10 or 15 years ago
right is that gender and sex suddenly
their definitions switched from being
the same thing to being sex and gender
are different things and I think my
opinion would be that those two
definitions shouldn't have been
separated in the first place where
you're different your opinions different
yeah so gender and sex have been
separate things for more than just 15
years
there are several Native American tribes
where your gender was not associated
with your sex the idea at least in
Western culture is fairly new when it's
contrasted with the Christian ideology
of two genders man and woman all that
yeah I think that's the predominant
thought process and
moral standing on that conclusion is
greco-roman scientific reasoning is the
basis for Western society so that's
where I would build that argument off of
I wouldn't call it scientific because
like I said it's what you believe it's
purely societal so opposition of gender
how would the scientific reasoning
differet ender from another other than
psychological like what physical
evidence could there be there doesn't
when it comes to gender the physical
evidence is how people present their
selves themselves we don't need to have
labels because I'd like to ask that how
many genders there are we don't need to
define that there can be an infinite
number of genders it's all about what
you define we don't need to say there
are two there are five there eight
that's unnecessary it's how you present
yourself there's there's more than just
masculine and feminine you there it's a
spectrum of how you present yourself Oh
for instance what a Tom girls still be a
girl then or is she a boy if she
believes she's a girl she's a girl she
can but does that contrast with the fact
that she has a vagina and two
x-chromosomes
not necessarily we're conflating the
idea of masculinity and femininity with
what you have in your pants which isn't
necessary you can present yourself any
way you want I could go around wearing a
dress if that's what I particularly
wanted to but are you still a boy then
because you have a penis
I don't assume you know what
sexually like scientifically I still
have a penis that makes me a male sex
yes the gender doesn't need to have a
label on it
okay so then we can agree that if you
have say an x and a y and you have a
penis you're a male no matter what but
you could identify as something else yes
you can identify as whatever you want to
identify with yeah you don't need you
nobody needs to conform to anything that
anybody else wants them to conform to
for a second
so since your job here is to change his
mind what I've heard you say is that
gender is separate
from sex yes what I've heard you present
is scientific arguments and you use
greco-roman reasoning as basically the
basis for Western society and culture
which would tell me that I believe
that's a value yes that you value
Western society yes okay you're telling
him that there are non Western societies
that may not should have values and
saying that you can identify or present
yourself as any gender that you would
like yes doesn't seem to me like that's
going to convince him of anything or
change his mind so let me do this let's
present you're kind of closing arguments
on this topic if you wanted him to see
one particular facet of your point of
view what do you think would be the most
convincing argument you could make to
someone who believes their only two
genders that gender and sex are not the
same thing that that's that's the basis
of my argument and a lot of arguments
and I hope that's what other people will
see that we don't have to assign
societal roles to what you have in your
pants okay and then Colton what would be
your closing argument or statement there
oh I like to point out for example like
I believe it's the CEO of Ford
industries as a woman I don't think
there's any particular I think we've
come far enough in a society that we can
let anybody do any societal role no
matter what's in their pants it doesn't
matter on what their gender identity is
and in fact that would somewhat be
sexism if you think about it if you had
to be a woman to I'd your gender had to
be a woman to do some societal role that
would be against reasoning good confer
do you guys feel is a good conversation
yeah good thanks Colton and Gilbert no
it's almost as though these two
different conversations mirrored each
other exactly in execution let me know
if you've spotted the trends yourself
comment below okay so we initially
planned this outing to be exclusively
between students but the students
themselves voted who would like to see
the next one be again with two students
conversing
okay who would like the next one to be
me sitting down with somebody and I
decided to have one more traditional
sit-down
on the topic of gender with UT's Lukas
what was your name sir I'm Lukas Lukas
nice to meet you would you mind
scooching in a little bit all right so
Lukas I I believe that there are only
two genders we've been talking about
this all day that one's pretty
straightforward changed my mind hi so I
think first and foremost the largest
question we've been asking today do you
think that sex and gender are two
separate things no no okay so in my view
I see sex is the biological factors that
differentiate men and women on the other
side gender is more the social and
cultural aspects and factors that
contribute to how people behave as male
or female and that's built up through
how parents and other important
individuals in our lives from childhood
build up and influence our behavior so I
think especially in today's day and age
gender is more not just biological
factors that define who we are it's
something that's changing and it's how
we identify if I someone as either male
or female and on what is that based the
idea that gender and sex are separate
where does that come from
it's sociology that's it's one of the
main topics it's one of the main like I
guess you could say fields of research
how they identify the difference between
gender and sex basically so I'd say
sociology mainly it's also some
psychology okay
sociology yes how long would you say
that's been the case it's I mean person
there in my view I think it's been a
constant case but I think especially now
it's a topic that's gaining a lot more
where does it stem from in Western
society I guess it's my question stem
from okay so me before we get there yeah
let me present yeah biological sex and
gender have been inextricably
intertwined sure pretty much the
entirety of Western civilization so when
I asked you what is this based on you
just presented an argument the gender
and sex are different I want to make
sure that understand you said that's
based on sociology
yes not based on science or medicine my
point of view is based on science and
medicine and the point of view that
you're presenting the reason I ask you
is it's very important this is a very
new idea so the idea that gender you
know or they're transgender the idea
that gender should be separated from sex
I came with a Simone de Beauvoir in the
1940s this doesn't come from science
this comes from post modernist
existentialism and even then it was
presented in the idea of a binary that a
male can have more female qualities or a
female can have more male qualities but
it's a societal construct you go all the
way through the janmani study you really
don't get to Judith Butler until the
1980s or 1990s who had this idea that
gender was based on a spectrum again
none of this is based in science none of
this is based in medical data or history
a more it's definitely a much newer idea
and topic but right I think also though
with when it comes to what was I can say
a gender on that topic I think you have
to consider though a lot more people how
it's bring into attention so how would
you identify so someone who was born
intersex someone who was born with the
genitalia of both men and women how
would you identify their gender
well first after a couple of things
they're good if I may address it a lot
of intersex people are born masculine or
feminine with a male or female with for
example some extra breast tissue or a
woman might have an enlarged clitoris
they're less than point zero one percent
of population Earth intersex and by the
way not all those people consider
themselves transgender LGBTQA so you
tation well I would say it's an anomaly
to medical anomaly for example what do
we teach children how many fingers are
toes do people have we teach them would
be at 5 and 10
I'm not gonna catch 5 or 10 we don't why
don't we teach them 20 because the
mature like you said the majority of the
right we have the same how many hearts
do people have we all have one okay we
all have one okay so we agree on that so
if we can put this extreme example off
the side for a second that's not how we
define male and female according to the
biology at the same time that's the same
argument as saying so how old are you
I'm 32 so you can't identify a saying or
I identify as 45 age is just not
something that's changing in society
it's the same argument and saying so
maybe a hundred years from now somebody
might argue that I can I
identify a city but today's day and age
general are already arguing exactly but
that's not something that we're already
recognizing in society as something on a
basis for argument why is because we
just haven't reached that point Society
what do you think we will I do think
that we will and so we think trans
ageism is a valid so see yeah I
definitely do not agree with that on the
on line Isis because for me I when we
start learning about certain things in
classes like gender sex I think it's a
viable issue in which we can identify
and people who identify well why I guess
my question here is I was going to ask
you know if you're going to uproot all
of modern Western civilization right
male female male female roles biology
sex gender was not removed from sex
until very recently we both agree on
that used to be really a grammatical
term it still is in a lot of the Romance
languages what is the net benefit to
completely removing gender from sex why
do that I don't think there's I
definitely don't think there's a net
benefit to completely removing them I
just think we need to recognize that
there is and I the way we identify it
and interpret it I think that there is
cause for understanding the difference
therein and that there are certain
people who and in society many people
actually who would like to have that
recognized and I do think that there is
some evidence on a scientific basis or
as well as sociological studies that
does give cause for understanding this
and interpreting it how so well in I
mean in society with the people that
identify as different genders right
and I mean it's on a one on one side
it's a matter of being able to consider
like acceptance in society feeling
comfortable at oneself but at the same
time we can still identify them as how
you want to identify but also letting
them to identify themselves in the way
that they would like to be so you're
saying would be okay if someone identify
male who identifies as female you
wouldn't have a problem with someone
like me
misgendering them using masculine
pronouns no I mean and in my classes we
recognize this all often times our TAS
will sometimes ask us I mean we want to
everyone has to go around to identify
your pronouns and I think that in often
times that's unnecessary why because we
all recognize I mean we all want to be
respectable right so I think in most
cases people aren't trying to
intentionally offend but why isn't it
necessary why didn't you ask me my
pronouns before you set down because I
don't in for a specially first
discussion like this it's unnecessary
why there's an unnecessary because for
you especially I think we can interpret
is that an important thing for you to
identify your pronouns sure okay so
let's say I do but you made a judgment
that it might not be important to me
right why well because in most cases the
people that do genuinely care a great
deal about it that is something that
they will present to you up front and in
the beginning and that was something
that what you just said you went around
in a classroom and asked people the
preferred pronouns why didn't you do it
why did you what did you assume I am I
assume your alias why that's an
assumption based on the fact well from
what I know of you already okay
so I have pre knowledge of that but in
the my example what I was stating as my
TA for they said let's they instructed
us to go around and go so basically like
it's just the direction of the tear they
wanted us to all identify our program
okay so I'm asking you you know for
example it's a very new concept yes you
weren't necessarily super familiar as to
where it came from
hopefully it may be that self look I
would encourage you to read some Simone
de Beauvoir and Judith Butler quite a
bit and read up on the twin study by at
janmani but I do think it's important if
you're going to say okay you've learned
this from your sociology professors on
this scenario that's kind of an appeal
to authority fallacy a little bit where
you saying well my professors say this
so I usually don't like appealing to
Authority but in this case I will every
doctor in the history of that room right
every biologist in the history of ever
kinesiologist would also have to look at
the difference in
the male and female body so we're going
to appeal to authority I certainly would
appeal to science and observable medical
data
I asked you what the net benefit is you
said there isn't necessarily one well I
think there's a huge net cost there's a
huge net cost if you say well there
aren't only two genders now there's a
burden of proof on you how many genders
are there I I believe that there are
three genders okay I think there are
male female and intersex
I don't think that we can consider just
intersex as a mutation I don't think
that's okay I don't think that's fair
and especially in our society I think
it's something we should consider but I
can put a number on so three something
so you wouldn't consider transgender or
gender you mean considered non-binary
gender no I don't think there's an
evidence yet enough to support that okay
so you really so you really just believe
that there's a third gender for people
who are born intersex exactly which I
think actually feasible to be medically
but that's a bit different from on your
sociology professors working well
professor yeah I think it was actually
the textbook yeah oh really yeah how
many injuries do they say there are they
don't put a number on it and that's why
I don't think there's evidence enough
for it yeah so once once you can put a
number and quality want to fire these
things I think you can start doing a
great deal more research and actually
get behind it okay once they have
something you can get behind specific so
well how would you identify someone who
let's say I says that they are trans
male to female trans I mean in how I
mean what do you mean though internally
or how would I present myself to them
because it's different right I'm not
saying you wouldn't felt them do you see
that person as a female you see that
person is male I in my view I just I see
them how they want to be interpreted
whether or not I actually don't real
recognize them or in internalize them as
being male or female that's different
but I always like try you make an effort
to internalize and present them how they
want to be seen so if someone who is say
a transgender female presents himself to
me as a female I will internalize that
as they are female I may also think and
might consciously think about them but
no you don't believe that those should
be recognized
no not monopoly no no okay so on a
driver's license it would still say male
or
well there you go we agree I think most
most ever yeah I appreciate it
oh there you have it twofold productive
conversations between students and one
between a student and myself let me know
what you think of the format what you'd
like to see next and as always be
prepared to rationalize your own
position see you next time
okay if you like this video you know you
watch videos on YouTube a fiber Jimmy
Kimmel if I were Stephen Colbert or
Trevor Noah
I would tell you to subscribe but I have
no corporate overlords
who demand that I do this demeaning
promo I do the demeaning promo because I
choose to subscribe or hit the
notification bell because I need you I
need you please do it